networking is super important to me at
this point you know there's two
different levels of networking for me
number one I'm in an environment where
I'm known right through the last decade
I've built up some brand equity and
there's a bit very different strategy of
walking into a room where there's
context around me I'm in a wine space in
the social media space marketing space
I'm gonna be able to play that way a
little bit different in that world I'm
kind of I'm receiving right I'm letting
things come to me this is the
opportunity for a lot of people to pitch
me I want to give them value and so in
those environments where I have context
and brand and leverage I actually give
back I actually just set up shop and I
get pitched for days on the other side
when I go to many places where nobody
knows who I am how many people in this
auditorium have no idea who I am raise
your hands that [ __ ] hurts I'm on the
offense to not overthink it so I will
never figure out like who's the biggest
dog or dog yet in the room that I want
to get to and like I'm gonna get minds
what I really do is I come in and really
go very open and create a scenario to
just let the serendipity take over I
think I think networking you get very
easy very quickly right you have such a
hardcore objective to me I let it come
to me that is my overall plan I by
nature and the counter-puncher from all
my aggression and bravado and what what
I project onstage because it's a
different environment in in in in real
life I'm very much let things come to me
and I like to react it's a little more
chess I wish I knew more about martial
arts because I feel like sometimes
people leave comments and Facebook and
YouTube now it's like it's like martial
art I like the other person's thing
give me the leverage to do my thing